oh we begin in Morocco where emergency
crews are racing to find earthquake
survivors the most destructive Quake for
more than 60 years on Friday killed at
least 2,000 people towns and villages in
the worsted areas have been wiped out as
you can see the Moroccan military has
been mobilized but rugged terrain there
is making it difficult to reach these
remote
communities all of us living in the
village here have lost our homes as you
can see all the people here today have
lost somebody somebody has died in every
family we are living in a crisis
situation we ask that King Muhammad the
six intervenes and sends us some help
because we are living through a
traumatizing situation the people don't
have electricity they have nothing to
eat or drink no bread
nothing well the epicenter of that
magnitude 6.8 Quake was in the Atlas
Mountains entire communities there have
been reduced to Rubble there's also been
widespread damage to in the his historic
city of Marakesh some 70 kilm away and
that's where our correspondent Jonah
Hull joins us from now Jonah another
night out there in the open for the
people around
you yes we were here last night in this
particular uh Square inside the Medina
the old city of Marakesh it was
absolutely full of people spending the
night outdoors uh in some cases they'v
been told by the police not to return to
their homes for fear of the structural
integ ity of some of those buildings
many though simply terrified of the
possibility of aftershocks and choosing
to remain Outdoors which they may well
do again in the evenings to come uh a
lots have moved on uh in the morning
light but still plenty of people here
taking shelter in the orings uh of shops
uh where they are making doe with pretty
uh meager Provisions what they've
managed to take from their homes they
are being supplied by volunteers a lot
of them quite angry complaining that
they're not being given any formal
assistance uh by the government and as I
say a lot have packed up some perhaps to
return to their homes if they've got
homes to return to some simply can't and
I'll show you why because we'll take you
now uh behind the scenes if you like
into one of a Warren of Alleyways that
exist in and around this Medina area
these are Alleyways where people live in
one two sometimes three story homes now
many many of them reduced simply to
Rubble the construction of these very
old buildings no match for Friday nights
uh earthquake and this is what the
authorities here in Marakesh and the
families who've been left homeless uh
will now have to contend with Jonah
clearly challenges there for the
community in Marakesh but also huge
concerns for the remote Mountain
communities who are closer to the
epicenter do we know how the rescue and
and Aid operation is going
there
well I think that really is the point
Marakesh 70 km uh from the epicenter
it's a builtup urban area much of its
infrastructure despite this remains
unscathed up in the mountain area a very
different story indeed across a pretty
wide area six provinces affected in the
alhaz region in the high Atlas uh
interior Ministry teams military teams
have been doing what they can to reach
very hard to reach in the best of times
rural communities much harder now
because of Rock Falls blocking uh
difficult Mountain Roads some places
have not received any help at all we
hear of places like Anne amm a town
called tarant that hasn't yet reached
any formal help funerals going on there
people digging with their hands through
Rubble to try and reach survivors basic
supplies running out joah Hall there for
us with the latest from the ground in
Morocco after that Quake Thank you very
much Jonah